[Musique]
aux abords des pâturages des vignobles
et des érablières il ya maintenant ici
de la fibre optique
de quoi offrir à tous les citoyens
l'accès à l'internet haute vitesse
ça va être exactement comme vous ce que
vous avez à montréal ça va l'être parce
qu'avec la sphère ya pas de limite pour
brancher tout le monde le maire dont le
recul n'a pas attendu les subventions de
l'état c'est la municipalité qui a payé
50 mille dollars ce qui équivaut à 125
dollars par habitant dont on aurait pu
attendre des historiens rapport au
besoin de payer à temps du cac
ça fait depuis 2000 à 2010 2012 qu'on
parle on a vu on est allé nouader des
rencontres avec la menace pipeau on
étale avec des rencontres avant tout les
morisques c'est toujours des promesses
mais rien qui aille inquiète nul en tout
onze municipalités de la mrc val saint
françois dans les cantons de l'est ont
participé au projet dont le maire de
stocks qui est aussi préfet de la mrc
on en a marre d'attendre les subventions
gouvernementales qui s'éternise on vos
pays qu'on va de la voix c'est ce qu'on
a fait un coût qui est même pas
comparable avec l'argent que le
gouvernement va donner aux grosses
compagnies pour brancher tout le monde
ça se compare même pas le coût total 450
mille dollars en fonds municipaux 450000
15 et 11 ans seulement le nahd année 1,2
million en compagnie de ceux qui bravent
deux municipalités
j'ai pas besoin d'être recherché depuis
les millions de dollars de subventions
du gouvernement ont permis de brancher à
peine 7000 foyers les 11 municipalités
elles ont fait branché 3300 maison
mancelle au bout des reins et ce en
moins de deux ans mais tout aurait pu
aller beaucoup plus vite dit la
directrice générale de cooptel qui a
piloté le projet juste pour vous donner
un exemple je je prends la décision de
même atteint de construire au complet
stocks mais ça me prend
deux trois semaines qui s'est terminée
la coopérative a dû longuement négociée
juste pour avoir accès aux poteaux tout
le processus de relever un générique
d'avoir les permis de faire les travaux
préparatoires
c'est ce qui prend le 2 ans en bout de
ligne mais construire en tant que tel
c'est paul ongles c'est ça se fait en
claquant des doigts obtenir l'accès aux
poteaux et si long et complexe
quant à plusieurs endroits la fibre
optique a été enfouies le long de la
route même si ça coûte trois fois plus
cher ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada overton
[Musique]